>> I WOULD THINK WE NEED THE
SUMMER FOR THE DIRECTION WE ARE
GOING TO GO.
IF WE ARE GOING IN THE DIRECTION
OF A SUBPOENA BATTLE, WE ARE
READY FOR THAT.
WE ARE REPRESENTING THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES,
LIFE WITHOUT NUCLEAR WEAPONS FOR
NORTH KOREA.
HOW CAN WE TAKE THREE OR FOUR
HOURS OR DAYS OUT OF THAT
SCHEDULE WHEN HE SHOULD BE
GETTING READY TO MEET WITH NORTH
KOREA.
>> I WOULD WRITE QUESTIONS AND
MAKE OBJECTIONS TO OTHERS BASED
ON ARTICLE 2 OF THE
CONSTITUTION.
>> RUDY JULIAN
>> RUDY GULIAN
>> RUDY GIUIAN
>> RUDY GIULIN
>> RUDY GIULIANI, THE
PRESIDENT'S NEW ATTORNEY TALKING
ABOUT CONDITIONS IN WHICH THE
PRESIDENT MAY SIT DOWN WITH
ROBERT MUELLER.
IT'S INTERESTING TO SEE THE
MOVEMENT IN THE LEGAL TEAM.
TY COB ON THE WAY OUT AND ON THE
WAY IN, EMMET FLOOD WHO WORKS
WITH THE CLINTON WHITE HOUSE ON
THE IMPEACHMENT, AND HAS A LOT
OF EXPERIENCE IN THIS AREA OF
DEALING WITH DEPOSITIONS AND
SPECIAL COUNSEL.
LET'S BRING IN AMY FROM SIRIUS
XM AND JONAH GOLDBERG AND AUTHOR